Let's discuss something that it often jokingly called Lhadma's
Law. This is really Amdahl spelled in reverse. And, it
says, that although Amdahl's Law pretty much tells us to
make the common case fast. We should not mess up
the uncommon case too badly while doing that. Let's
consider an example, in which we can achieve an improvement
of a factor of 2, or 90% of the execution
time. So, we can achieve a speed up of 2,
or 90% of the execution time. But at the cost of slowing down the rest by 10x.
Meaning the remaining 10% now gets 10 times as much execution time as before.
The overall speed up can be now expressed
as, both of these are affected by different
so called improvements. We have one of them, the 10%, is effected by a speed up
of 0.1 because this is a 10 times slow down, this is a slow down
of 0.1. And the other the 90% are
sped up by a factor of 2 and we get 1 over 1 plus
0.45 equal 0.7. So we actually got an overall slowdown.
In fact even with an infinite improvement on 90%, this will
become 0. We will still have a speed of
1, meaning no improvement. So basically, if you have
a huge worsening on even a small part of
the execution time, the overall speedup will not be good.